but i would also say there's been a big
lesson i've learned that is anytime
people live anytime you discover a group
of people who are very interested in and
living a lifestyle that is different
than yours it's very easy initially to
write it off and just say oh that's
frivolous that's um that's just kind of
like whatever you know they're out of
touch or
uh they're weird or whatever like it
doesn't really matter what what category
it is like when i when i saw gamers and
people who stream video games and watch
other people playing video games it was
so strange to me i remember making fun
of this kid in college
because i walked in on him and he was
watching somebody else play a video game
on a live stream and the guy was playing
in korea and i was like you're watching
a dude in korea play this video game why
don't you just play better yet why don't
you get outside and like let's go go get
some food and i made fun of him for and
then years later i'm like selling my
company to twitch and like i'm i'm like
talking about how great this trend is
and he's like called me he's like you
motherfu you know like i dude you made
fun of me for this 10 years ago and here
you are now like now you're on board and
that's happened to me so many times in
life that now i go the exact opposite
way i see some somebody like you
who says the same thing that our other
buddy said which is maybe i should go to
the mayo clinic and get these advanced
scans done once a year i think huh maybe
that's something more people are going
to want to do why would he want to do
this why are people choosing plant-based
lifestyles what is that all about you
know like and so now i lean in any time
i discover these things and that's
become some of the best a like either
like discoveries life changes i can make
or b investments it's a great way to
invest because you're actually on the
like the cutting edge of stuff you're in
early which is super important obviously
there's a book on like a famous business
book on it where he talks i think it's
crossing the chasm or something where he
talks about like early adopters and then
like the there's basically this like
bell curve of people where it's like in
the beginning of the belt curve it's
like late people who are late to it and
then like the middles like the average
joe and there's like early adopters and
then there's one more like cutting edge
and you and i both have like a handful
of friends of which i would actually say
that i i forget the names of them but in
that bell curve there's people who are
getting names because you got the idea
right but you uh like butchered all the
names so it's basically the earliest is
innovators and it's like the people
actually like figuring things out and
then there's early adopters then there's
early majority that's the kind of like
big chunk late majority that's the other
part of the big chunk and then there's
the laggards who are like you know
people who still have aol email
addresses and like you know
are looking driving around looking for
blockbusters and for a lot of things i
would say you are on the right side
you're uh either an innovator or the one
next to it an early adopter
and i'm trying to go i'm intent i'm
intentionally trying to go that way so i
thought
uh you know i'm just not that i'm not
like a futurist type of guy because i've
been so wrong
and i figured out the formula for it the
formula for it is um have an ego
make a prediction
be wrong like five times and have it
rubbed in your face how wrong you were
boom you're not you're now a futurist uh
like i remember the first time the
iphone came out and i was like who the
wants to like read tiny text on a
screen like that's awful i was like
nobody's gonna watch a movie on this i
was like yeah you can watch who would
ever watch a movie on this like tiny
square like that's like that would be
the worst it's worse than an airplane
headrest like i remember saying these
things to people and you know like i was
in college i was like a junior in
college there was nobody remembers this
but i remember being that wrong snapchat
i remember being that wrong my username
still has the word test in it because i
was so certain
i was like snapchat this is this is
stupid right this is just for kids and
dick pics and stuff like that like
certainly won't go on beyond this
bitcoin i was wrong early on right like
guys in my office were telling me about
it back in 2012 2013 and i was kind of
laughing and saying guys let's focus on
something like legit here and now i'm
like you know a bitcoin
evangelist and so like twitch same thing
i was wrong about streaming i've been
wrong so many times that i've actually
flipped the script now i kind of had to
reassess my life and say
i'm not gonna be very good as a
technology entrepreneur or technology
investor if i just continue to write off
the big things as dumb and stupid early
on like i need to go the exact opposite
way okay what would it take for me to do
that and i just i just inverted so
instead of you know anytime i see that
the same feeling i instead lean into
curiosity what's making people want to
do this
when i think it's so strange and now
that's that's like flipped the script
for me and we either had justin or
emmett on at hustlecon or on here and
they're talking about justin tv which
was the site before twitch became a
thing and it was basically
uh anyone could log in and create their
own live tv channel and emmett i believe
you could tell me if i'm wrong i believe
the story was like emmett with like
there's a small corner of the site where
these like guys were watching video
games and it wasn't a lot of people like
thousands of people but they were
spending two percent i think of the
traffic um
at that time but they were spending a
significant amount of time watching and
he was like that's this is the one that
we got to go to and and i don't even
think it was that as data-driven
actually the data pointed against it
because again i remember it was a small
trap it was a small amount they had a
combination of two things working in
their favor
number one emmett was like i i guess
actually the number one factor was
they were the current thing
wasn't working and they had like no like
they had nothing to lose they don't they
were gonna run out of money and fail or
they had to try something dramatically
different and
when you feel like you're and you
have nothing to lose you actually have
the one of the greatest assets on your
side um which is that you know when you
have nothing to lose you play completely
differently than when you feel like you
have something to lose so that was the
first thing they had to change they the
things that were popular were all like
illegal streams it's legal streams of
sports so they knew
oh people want to watch this but we
can't ever build a business around this
yeah so what 90 of people are doing on
this site we can't use the two percent
thing worked and then the other one was
he was like
i personally like watching these so he's
like
i'm gonna go with that
like these are my favorite things to
watch on the network so if i'm gonna
work on this i'm gonna work on the ones
that i personally find you know the most
interesting and actually most of the
company wanted to go work on the hotter
sexier idea which was called uh what was
the thing called the video thing they
had not vidi their their their version
of that called social capital
cam so the company split in half they
said all right justin tv is not gonna
work abandon ship and we gotta figure
out you know what's the what's the
emergency ship and so
they had this i think michael cybel who
now runs y combinator and justin khan
they wanted to do social cam it was
instagram for video instagram is the
hottest startup in silicon valley but
it's photos we're gonna do instagram for
video
and they were able to instantly raise
money they got tons of initial hype and
traction and press and all the talented
people in the company wanted to go work
there so i talked to this guy jacob
who's the
og designer at twitch and he's still
there he's still at the company today
and i said uh how'd you know like to bet
on twitch instead of social cam he goes
oh no dude i wanted to be on social camp
they were just like nah like we don't
like
teams full bro like you go work on on
the thing with emmett because emma's his
childhood friend he said you got to go
to that one he's like oh all right
whatever
you know so like that was what seemed
like the great idea but actually
what emmett did which was leaned into
this really weird behavior unique
lifestyle that these gamers were doing
where they were streaming themselves
playing for eight hours a day that
turned out to be the thing and that's
kind of my point which is like i think
that there's like these i i do it on
online communities particularly reddit
but you can right now you can do it on
twitter or you can just type in like any
idea or any hobby and type in the word
forum and you can just find like these
niche communities of people that are
kind of freaks and it's fun to like
learn all about it like for example
intermittent fasting fasting is now like
we all talk about it um i remember like
eight years ago i remember business
insider wrote an article about
like a microsoft executive and they
mocked him for the like intermittent
fasting what is this and uh but there's
there's been communities online where
i've like read about people doing this
for forever and you're like fasting like
no like breakfast is the most important
meal of the day just look at anything
they make fun of silicon valley for at
the beginning coronavirus like vcs are
so paranoid about the real world that
they're wearing masks to conferences
guess what everybody's doing now i'm
wearing masks right
oh my god intermittent fasting silicon
valley's latest craze not eating till
noon every day you know what a google
what google engineers are doing right
it's like
media loves to make fun of it guess what
that's what everybody's going to be
doing um you know what are some other
things that are like that i think you
know some of them are
meditation by the way was like that too
people made fun of it and then you know
boom it's like the new yoga
uh the other ones i think that are
happening are like stem cell or any like
blood platelet spinning stuff where it's
like oh you have knee pain well these
guys they like go to puerto rico and
like go to germany and like get this
blood spinning treatment and go
get stem cells injected on their knees
that and uh now they feel good and gene
editing i think is gene editing's one
another one uh breath work i think
breath work is where meditation was i
invested this thing called other ships
they just actually launched their app i
use it every single day and um like i
use it religiously because it makes you
feel so good and to to the average
person like i do it outside now after
huberman was like get get some light on
your eyes first thing in the morning so
i do it outdoors um and i'm sitting in
my driveway basically doing it and
neighbors are walking by they're walking
their dog what they feel is a very
normal behavior go go for a morning walk
and they see me like doing
breathing techniques on my driveway and
they think i'm a nut uh and i love it i
go louder as soon as somebody walks by
because i want them to know they live
next to somebody from the future dude
there's this guy his name was bill uh
well we'll start with there's this guy
named arthur leonard he's uh he's dead
now but in the 60s and 70s he was a new
zealand track and field coach and he had
runners like paul walker uh or not paul
walker that's john walker uh peter fury
yeah yeah peter snell and all these like
new zealand guys who started winning the
olympics in the 1500 meters 5k and 10k
and everyone's like dude what are you
doing with your runners and he goes we
run like 120 miles a week we do long
distance running and we go slow and we
just do it just a shitload of it and
this one coach from oregon got really
interested and uh his name was bill
bowerman and he goes well i'm the track
and field coach at oregon university i
have all these great runners what are
you doing and he goes over to in the
1970s in new zealand and he learns from
arthur leonard and he comes back and he
starts making it popular and two things
happen university oregon gets really
good at track and field and he ends up
um
making shoes for his runners so they can
run a little bit faster and he calls it
nike he calls that company nike he
starts it with a with another runner
phil knight
and the other thing that happens and
this just it worked out perfectly is he
starts talking about it to all of his
friends he even writes a book about it
and i believe it's called like the joy
of jogging and the idea of jogging it
wasn't even like a thing in the 70s
people like what do you mean you're just
going to run like art isn't
yeah like aren't the police gonna go
after you and and like like it was like
astounding like prior to the 1970s right
so there was it was a jogging craze of
the 70s prior to that people didn't go
out and run that just like wasn't like a
thing and so anyway that's like another
example where like running became
popular and bowerman created nike to
kind of capitalize on it